This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. This summer, the governors of New Mexico and Colorado got into a fight on Twitter. Words were had, umbridge was taken, but the fight wasn't over tax incentives or highway funding or water rights. Instead, it all boiled down to this. Colorado's governor had the gall to insult New Mexico's pride and joy. It's chili peppers.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马斯。今年夏天，新墨西哥州和科罗拉多州的州长在推特上大打口水战。双方唇枪舌剑，互不相让，但这场争端无关税收优惠、高速公路资金或水权。归根结底，原因只有一个。科罗拉多州州长竟然大言不惭地侮辱了新墨西哥州的骄傲与灵魂——辣椒。
The latest war of words comes after Colorado's governor made some insulting comments about our chili. Colorado's governor, Jared Polis, is claiming the chili in Pueblo is better than ours. Naturally, New Mexico's governor had no choice but to respond in kind. This morning, Governor Michelle Lujan-Krischum defended our precious crop on Twitter, saying, quote, If Weblo chili were any good, it would have been on national shelves before now. In New Mexico, chili peppers are everywhere. Restries of dried chilies hang from every doorway. They are prominently featured on license plates.
这场最新的口水战起因于科罗拉多州州长对我们的辣椒发表了一些侮辱性言论。科罗拉多州州长贾里德·波利斯声称普韦布洛的辣椒比我们的更好。自然而然，新墨西哥州州长别无选择，只能针锋相对。今天早上，米歇尔·卢汉·格里沙姆州长在推特上捍卫了我们宝贵的农作物，她写道：“如果韦布洛辣椒真有什么过人之处，早就该摆上全国各地的货架了。”在新墨西哥州，辣椒随处可见。一串串风干的辣椒挂在每个门廊前。它们在车牌上占据着显眼的位置。
Chili pepper cheeseburgers are part of the standard menu at McDonald's. I can report, they are not very good. And New Mexico remains the only state in the union with an official state question. Red or green? It's Chili season right now in New Mexico, which means that the state's chili pepper pride is ramped up to the next level. That's reporter Rose Eveleth, host of the Flash Forward podcast. There are chili-cented candles for sale. The roads are dotted with big white signs that say, fresh chili this way, and every parking lot seems to have a roaster going, tumbling green and
辣椒芝士汉堡是麦当劳的标配菜单。我可以作证，它们其实不太好吃。新墨西哥州依然是全美唯一一个拥有官方州级问卷的州。红的还是绿的？现在正清新墨西哥州的辣椒季，这意味着该州对辣椒的自豪感达到了顶峰。这是《Flash Forward》播客的主持人、记者罗斯·埃维莱特带来的报道。市面上有各种辣椒味的蜡烛出售。道路两旁点缀着醒目的白色标示，上面写着“新鲜辣椒往这走”，每个停车场似乎都有一个在转动的烘烤炉，将红绿辣椒在明火上不断翻烤。
red chili peppers over a fire. And in September 2019, on an incredibly windy day in Sakura, the New Mexico Chili Association hosted the first ever New Mexico Chili Taste Off. And when I asked farmers at the chili taste off about the rivalry with Colorado, they basically just laughed. No, Colorado doesn't scare us. Bring it on. She asked us if we were worried about Colorado chili. Oh, not at all.
在2019年9月索科罗一个风大得惊人的日子里，新墨西哥州辣椒协会举办了历史上第一届新墨西哥州辣椒品尝大赛。当我向参加品尝大赛的农户询问与科罗拉多州的竞争时，他们基本上只是付诸一笑。“不，科罗拉多吓不倒我们。尽管放马过来。”她问我们是否担心科罗拉多辣椒。“哦，一点也不。”
Not at all. No, if I want to go to Colorado for something, it will be for chili. I might go skiing. But probably not even that. Amidst all this Colorado trash talking, the organizers of the chili taste off also crowned the chili queen of New Mexico.
“一点也不。不，如果我要去科罗拉多做点什么，那一定是去滑雪，为了别的可不行。或许连滑雪都不至于。”在科罗拉多人的各种大放厥词中，辣椒品尝大赛的组织者还加冕了新墨西哥州的辣椒女王。
June Rutherford, your royal chili highness, is 95 years old. June has been in the business since she was a little girl, when her father carried her around in the fields in a pepper sack. There's even a chili pepper variety named after her, the Miss Juni. And she wasn't going to let a little wind stop her from talking up New Mexico, Chile. Our chili has a better taste than anywhere else and I'm not bragging. There's nobody, Texas, Arizona, California, and even Colorado can't beat us. They can't beat us. We have something that nobody's gone. There's no secret ingredient to New Mexico's chili peppers, unless you count tradition.
琼·卢瑟福，您的辣椒皇室殿下，今年已经95岁了。琼从小就开始从事辣椒行业，那时她的父亲把她装在胡椒麻袋里抱进田里。甚至还有一个以她的名字命名的辣椒品种，叫“小琼”。她可不会让一点微风阻挡她为新墨西哥州辣椒大加赞赏。“我们的辣椒比任何地方的都好吃，我可不是在吹牛。没有人——德克萨斯、亚利桑那、加利福尼亚，甚至科罗拉多——都赢不了我们。他们赢不了我们。我们拥有别人没有的东西。”新墨西哥州的辣椒没有什么秘密配料，除非你把传统也算作一种。
New Mexicans like June have been growing their own varieties for over a hundred years. Mostly unsmall family farms that remain dedicated to this one beloved crop for generations. But despite these growers pride in their peppers, all is not well in Miss Juni's kingdom. New Mexico's chili may be the best in the world, but for a while now, the chili business has been in trouble. New Mexico chili farmers have a problem, one that might soon force them to choose between tradition and technology. When I started reporting this story,
像琼这样的新墨西哥州人培育自己的品种已经有一百多年了。这些大多是小型家庭农场，世世代代专注种植这唯一的挚爱作物。但尽管这些种植者对自己的辣椒充满骄傲，“小琼”的王国里并非一帆风顺。新墨西哥州的辣椒可能是世界上最好的，但一段时间以来，辣椒产业一直陷入困境。新墨西哥州的辣椒农面临着一个问题，这个问题可能很快迫使他们在传统与技术之间做出抉择。当我开始报道这个故事时，
everybody told me I had to talk to a guy named Glenn Duggins. They told me that Glenn was a great, cheery, friendly guy. But when I first called him about chili, and I asked, is this Glenn? He answered, what's left of him? Do you ever get nostalgic about the old chili days?
每个人都告诉我，我必须去和一个叫格伦·杜金斯的人聊聊。他们说格伦是个开朗、热情、友好的人。但当我第一次因为辣椒的事打电话给他，问“请问是格伦吗？”他回答道：“还剩下个架子呢。”你对过去的辣椒岁月有过怀旧之情吗？
Yeah, I miss them. It was easy. I miss them. Help was easy. Everybody made money. We stayed drunk most of the time. I mean, we had a good time at it. It's not nearest fun anymore.
“对，我很怀念。那时候很简单。我很怀念。那时很好招人。每个人都能赚钱。我们大部分时间都喝得醉醺醺的。我是说，我们那时候过得很开心。现在可一点意思也没有了。”
Glen runs a chili farm called Five Star Chili in Sacoro, New Mexico. And he says that every year things get a little more bleak for the business. It's not that nobody wants to buy chili. Nationwide demand for chili peppers is at an all-time high. And yet, the economics of being a chili farmer, they're just not working out. It's been wild this year. It was bad weather, but it's more than that. It's like the perfect storm came together.
格伦在新墨西哥州索科罗经营着一家名为“五星辣椒”的辣椒农场。他说，这个行业的情况每年都在变得更加黯淡。并不是没有人想买辣椒。全国对辣椒的需求处于历史最高水平。然而，作为一名辣椒农的经济账，却怎么也算不过来。今年简直太疯狂了。天气很糟，但原因不止于此。这就好像是一场完美的风暴聚在了一起。
We had bad weather. You have fewer farmers. You have fewer acres. To make matters worse, chili grown in Mexico is often trucked over the border, labeled as New Mexico chili and sold for far cheaper than the farmers in the state can compete with. But Glenn says that there's one thing in particular that has him and other chili farmers especially worried. Chili farmers are used to bad weather, to competition, to all that other stuff. But now, even if they had perfect weather, perfect crop of chilies and no competition at all, they'd still have a
我们遇到了糟糕的天气。农户减少了。种植面积减少了。雪上加霜的是，在墨西哥种植的辣椒经常被卡车运过边境，贴上新墨西哥州辣椒的标签出售，价格比本州农户的成本低得多，根本无法竞争。但格伦说，有一件事尤其让他和其他辣椒农忧心忡忡。辣椒农习惯了恶劣天气、竞争以及所有其他风风雨雨。但现在，即便他们拥有完美的天气、完美的辣椒收成且没有任何竞争，他们依然会面临一个问题。
problem. There just aren't enough workers to pick the peppers. We hire everybody that comes up, everybody. When I visited Glenn's farm, he had eight workers out in the field, picking chiles. He says on a good year in the past, he would have had 30, mostly from Mexico. They would go to one ranch house, work a few days for them, they would feed them, take care of them, and this and that, and go to the next ranch house, and they would eventually get here. That hasn't happened in years.
根本没有足够的工人来采摘辣椒。我们把来应聘的人全招了，所有人都是。当我参观格伦的农场时，他有八个工人在地里采摘辣椒。他说，在过去的一个好年景里，他会雇30个人，大部分来自墨西哥。他们会去一个农庄，为他们干几天活，农庄管饭、照顾他们诸如此云，然后再去下一个农庄，最后他们总能来到这里。这种情况已经多年没有发生了。
Ten years ago, he used to wake up in the morning at the start of Chile season, and have the 30 guys he needed just standing in his driveway. They just show up. Look at your door. Are they snog on your door? Yeah, they know where to go. And they're not showing up. They're not showing up.
十年前，在辣椒季刚开始的早晨，他醒来时，他需要的30个小伙子就会直接站在他的车道上。他们自己就会出现。“看看你的门。他们会在敲你的门吗？”“对，他们知道该去哪里。但他们现在不来了。他们不来了。”
It's not just Glenn, and it's not just the Chile industry. Farms across the United States are reporting shortages of labor. Since 2002, the number of immigrants coming to the United States to work in agriculture has dropped by 75%. In California, one survey found that 56% of farmers were unable to hire enough workers. The number of people immigrating to the US for farm labor has actually been going down since 2008, like when the economy crashed here. That's Sarah Taber, a crop scientist based in Fayetteville, North Carolina.
不只是格伦，也不只是辣椒产业。全美各地的农场都在报告劳动力短缺。自2002年以来，来到美国从事农业劳工的移民数量下降了75%。在加利福尼亚州，一项调查发现，56%的农场主无法雇到足够的工人。事实上，为了从事农业劳动力而移民美国的人数自2008年以来一直在下降，就像当年这里的经济崩溃时一样。这是常驻北卡罗来纳州费耶特维尔的农作物科学家莎拉·泰伯说的。
And she says the Great Recession scrambled the familiar labor paradigm, in which migrant workers would arrive in the U.S. looking for work on farms. Um, a lot of folks were like, wait, I can actually do better for myself just staying home in Mexico. Increasingly, potential foreign workers are staying put in their home countries to work in places like call centers. And Sarah points out that the children of immigrants who came to the US and went into agriculture, they're not following suit. So the folks who already came to the US are from labor, they're getting older, and their kids are not going into that. They're here to make their lives better, and they're like, please kids, don't go into picking chilies.
她说，大萧条打乱了以往熟悉的劳动力模式，过去季节工会来到美国寻找农场工作。“嗯，许多人觉得，‘等等，我其实留在墨西哥老家，日子也能过得更好。’”越来越多的潜在外国劳工选择留在祖国，去呼叫中心等地工作。莎拉指出，那些来到美国并从事农业的移民的子女，并没有子承父业。因此，那些来美国从事农业劳工的人正在变老，而他们的孩子并不打算从事这一行。他们来这里是为了过上更好的生活，他们父母会说：“求求孩子们，别去摘辣椒。”
It's not even that this work doesn't pay well. It does. Farm laborers in New Mexico's chili fields can make double the state's minimum wage. They can make nearly twice as much picking chili as they could working at a chili's restaurant. But they still don't want to do it. In part because picking chili peppers can be especially grueling work, even compared to other crops. Chili plants grow low to the ground, and the chilis themselves often sit close to the stem nestled deep inside the bush.
甚至不是因为这项工作报酬不好。其实挺不错的。新墨西哥州辣椒田里的农业工人的工资可以达到该州最低工资的两倍。他们采摘辣椒的收入几乎是在辣椒餐厅（Chili's）打工的两倍。但他们依然不愿意干。部分原因在于，即便与其他农作物相比，采摘辣椒也是一项格外折磨人的艰苦工作。辣椒植株长得很矮，辣椒本身往往紧贴着主茎，深深地隐藏在灌木丛深处。
So workers have to hunch over in the hot sun to get them. All this while wearing gloves to protect their hands from the oils that give chilies their characteristic heat. And green chili peppers, the kind of gland and a lot of other New Mexico chili farmers rely on, are especially hard to pick. Green chilies are just unripe red chilies, which means that the seeds inside of them aren't ready to germinate yet. The plant doesn't want to give its fruits up, so its stems won't let go without a fight.
因此，工人们必须在烈日下弯腰驼背才能摘到辣椒。与此同时，他们还得戴着手套，以保护双手免受辣椒素的侵扰，正是这种油脂赋予了辣椒标志性的辣味。而青辣椒——格伦和许多其他新墨西哥州辣椒农所依赖的品种——格外难以采摘。青辣椒只是未成熟的红辣椒，这意味着它们内部的种子还没有准备好发芽。植物不想放弃它的果实，所以它的茎部不经过一番较量是绝不会松手的。
And we hire people every year like citizens here that need a job and know I can do that and they quit by noon. It's too hard, it's not the money, they don't want to stoop over and pick chili or whole weeds, they won't do it. I mean, I'm not gonna do it, are you? In order to stay afloat, small family farms like Glens have been planting less and less chili every year in favor of other less labor intensive crops. In 1997, New Mexico chili farmers planted over 30,000 acres. Last year, there was only 8400.
“我们每年都会雇人，比如需要工作的本地公民，他们觉得自己能胜任，但到中午就辞职了。太辛苦了，不是钱的问题，他们就是不想弯腰驼背地去摘辣椒或拔杂草，他们不肯干。我是说，我自己也不干，你干吗？”为了维持生计，像格伦这样的小型家庭农场每年都在减少辣椒的种植面积，转而种植其他劳动强度较小的作物。1997年，新墨西哥州的辣椒种植面积超过3万英亩。去年，这一数字仅剩下8400英亩。
And now some younger farmers are opting not to plant chili at all. As Glenn showed me around his farm, he pointed out into the distance where his son was driving a tractor, raking up hay. You're going to take over after you retire? I think, but he won't do chili, I bet. Why not?
如今，一些年轻的农场主选择根本不种辣椒。当格伦带我参观他的农场时，他指着远处他的儿子正开着拖拉机在收割牧草。“你退休后他会接手吗？”“我想会的，但我敢打赌他不会种辣椒。”“为什么不呢？”
He sees what I go through. He won't, I go through it. I mean, what we have, we made years ago. We haven't done anything in the last six, eight years. Do you think it'll ever get back to that? No. Why not? I don't see how the, the, the, the, how.
“他看到了我经历的一切。他不会的，我经历过这些。我是说，我们现在有的，都是多年前赚下的。在过去六八年里，我们什么也没做成。”“你觉得还能回到过去那样吗？”“不能。”“为什么不呢？”“我想不通怎么能，怎么能，怎么能，怎么能。”
Glenn genuinely doesn't know the answer to that question, nor do a lot of other chili farmers. But if you've been paying attention to almost every other industry, you might be wondering, why can't Glenn just get a machine to pick his peppers? After all, it wouldn't be the first time a machine has replaced human hands in the field. Especially, as Sarah Tabor points out, in a country with abundant land and scarce labor. It's always been very easy if you are a white person in the United States to get your own land. And as a result, you can get way more land than you can actually work yourself pretty
格伦真心不知道这个问题的答案，许多其他辣椒农也是如此。但如果你关注过几乎所有其他行业，你可能也会纳闷：为什么格伦不能买台机器来摘辣椒呢？毕竟，机器取代田间人力的事已经不是第一次发生了。正如莎拉·泰伯所指出，尤其在一个土地资源丰富、劳动力稀缺的国家。“在美国，如果你是个白人，要弄到自己的土地历来都非常容易。因此，你可以轻松获得远超你个人实际耕种能力的土地，那么你该怎么处理它呢？”
easily, so then what do you do with it? In the south, landowners cultivated more land than they could on their own through the use of slavery. After slavery was outlawed, the same landowners increasingly rented their land out on unfair terms to sharecroppers, and in the north to tenant farmers who would harvest things like grain. So like, grain used to be really, really super labor intensive. You had to cut it by hand, you had to dry it, stack it, fresh it, you know all that stuff
在南方，土地所有者通过使用奴隶制，耕种了远超他们单凭自己所能管理的土地。废除奴隶制后，这些土地所有者转而以不公平的条件将土地租给佃农，在北方则租给种植谷物等作物的佃农。所以，比如，谷物过去曾经需要极其巨大的人力。你必须用手割它、晾晒、堆叠、脱粒，你知道，所有这些活儿都是手工完成的。
that was all done by hand. But then in the 1880s, commercial production began on a Combine Harvester, a machine that could do it all at once. That's why they call it a Combine. The Combine Harvester allowed landowners to harvest all their grain themselves. No extra help required. So they kicked all the tenant farmers off the land and kept the profits for themselves. No extra help required. So they kicked all the tenant farmers off the land and kept the profits for themselves. The American agricultural industry has been
但到了18世纪80年代，联合收割机开始投入商业生产，这是一种能同时完成所有这些工序的机器。这也是为什么它被称为“联合”。联合收割机让土地所有者能够自己收割所有的谷物，无需额外的帮手。因此，他们把所有的佃农赶出土地，将利润收入囊中。无需额外的帮手。因此，他们把所有的佃农赶出土地，将利润收入囊中。从那时起，美国农业产业便一直在忙于实现自动化。
busy automating things ever since. In 1936, the first practical cotton picking machine was demonstrated in Mississippi. That same year, a patent was filed for the first fully automatic hay baler. And in 1963, a team at UC Davis released a machine that could harvest tomatoes. More recently, machines have started harvesting everything from olives to potatoes to carrots. So why not chilies? Well, it turns out it's not easy for a machine to pick a pepper. In the beginning, I was definitely the optimism of being new at it. So I think I even had a growers ask me, then, how long?
1936年，第一台实用的采棉机在密西西比州进行了演示。同年，第一台全自动打草机申请了专利。1963年，加州大学戴维斯分校的一个团队推出了一台可以收割西红柿的机器。最近，机器开始收割从橄榄、土豆到胡萝卜的一切农作物。那么，为什么不能收割辣椒呢？好吧，事实证明，机器要摘辣椒可不容易。一开始，我绝对充满了新手的乐观。所以我想我甚至还遇到有农户问我：“那么，还需要多久？”
And I think I would sit back then five years, and I have to laugh. This is Stephanie Walker, a crop scientist at New Mexico State University, who for the past 15 years has been leading a team working on the holy grail of chiles, figuring out a way to pluck a green chili pepper off a plant with a machine. When Stephanie first started, automatic harvesters for ripe, ready to pick red chili peppers were already in the process of being perfected, but she wanted to figure out a way to have them harvest green chili, the kind farmers like Glenn rely on. Stephanie says that in those early days,
我想我当时回答的是五年，现在想想真得笑出声来。这是新墨西哥州立大学的农作物科学家斯蒂芬妮·沃克，在过去15年里，她一直领导着一个团队致力于攻克辣椒领域的“圣杯”——研究出一种用机器将青辣椒从植株上摘下来的方法。当斯蒂芬妮刚开始时，针对成熟、随时可摘的红辣椒的自动收割机已经处于完善的过程中，但她想要找出一种方法，让它们能够收割青辣椒——也就是像格伦这样的农户所依赖的品种。斯蒂芬妮说，在早期，
she tried out a bunch of different red chili harvesters and matched them against common varieties of green chili. But the results were disastrous. When they came up against the unripe green peppers with their tough stems and their hard to reach locations, it was like the machine just didn't know what to do. Instead of picking the peppers off the plant, the machine would literally rip up the entire plant
她尝试了各种各样的红辣椒收割机，并将其与常见的青辣椒品种进行匹配。但结果却是一场灾难。当它们遇到那些带坚韧茎干、位置刁钻的未成熟青辣椒时，机器简直不知所措。机器非但没有把辣椒从植株上摘下来，反而会字面意义上连根拔起整株植物，
and try to stuff it in its mouth, like some kind of mechanical toddler choking on a toy. There was one I remember that the plants were very, very large and bushy, and what the machine was basically doing was just tearing up the plants and shredding them. Another machine they tested had the opposite problem. It was a very gentle, combing mechanism through the plants, so the fruit weren't broken, but it was so gentle, we left more than 40% of the fruit out in the field.
并试图把它塞进嘴里，就像某种机械小屁孩在被玩具噎住一样。我记得其中一台机器，当时植株长得非常巨大且茂密，而机器基本上所做的就是撕裂和粉碎这些植物。他们测试的另一台机器则遇到了相反的问题。它是一种非常温和的梳理机构，穿过植株时不会损坏果实，但由于它实在太温柔了，导致田里遗留了超过40%的果实。
Stephanie and her team tried machine after machine, but none of them were a match for the chili pepper. The successful crop automations of the past might make you think that the chili pepper is an outlier, a stubborn holdout against two centuries of agricultural and technological progress. But in fact, chili is just one of many crops that machines still can't harvest as well as humans. If at all, asparagus, cherries, apples, saffron, chocolate, they're all still harvested by
斯蒂芬妮和她的团队尝试了一台又一台机器，但没有一台能搞定辣椒。过去成功的作物自动化可能会让你觉得辣椒是个特例，是在两个世纪农业和技术进步面前顽固不化的钉子户。但事实上，辣椒只是机器至今仍无法像人类那样完美收割的众多作物之一。如果说还能收割的话，芦笋、樱桃、苹果、藏红花、巧克力，至今全部仍然是由手工采摘的。
hand. In many ways, automating certain crop harvests is still a lot harder than automating something like, say, a car factory. And the reason for this is actually pretty simple. Crops are not like cars. It's very easy for a robot to install a windshield or put the lug nuts on a wheel or lift an engine into a chassis because each component is near identical
在许多方面，实现某些作物收割的自动化，仍然比自动化像汽车厂那样的生产线要困难得多。而原因其实非常简单。农作物和汽车不一样。机器人安装挡风玻璃、给车轮拧螺母或将发动机吊入底盘非常容易，因为每个部件都与前一个部件近乎完全相同。
to the component that preceded. David Otter is an economist at MIT, who studies the interaction of technology and labor. And he says that automation works great when a machine is placed in a highly regulated, highly predictable setting, like an assembly line. However, outside of that setting in the natural world, things tend to have a lot of variety, and they tend to be rather delicate. So it's simply not the case that every heirloom tomato has the exact shape and size of every other heirloom tomato. Nor is it the case that the effort that would be required to pluck it off the vine would
大卫·奥特是麻省理工学院的一名经济学家，专门研究技术与劳动的相互作用。他说，当机器被放置在一个高度规整、高度可预测的环境（比如装配线）中时，自动化效果极佳。然而，在那个环境之外的自然界中，事物往往具有极大的多样性，而且它们往往相当脆弱。因此，绝非每个传家宝西红柿都具有与其他传家宝西红柿完全相同的形状和大小。也绝非将它从藤蔓上摘下来所需的力气在所有情况下都是完全相同的。所以这是一个非常具有挑战性的机械化环境。因此，如果你想实现收割自动化，你不能仅仅找到一台出色的机器。你必须实现标准化。所以，如果你想实现收割自动化，你不能仅仅找到一台出色的机器。你必须对你的植物进行标准化。换句话说，你必须让农作物更像汽车。
be identical in all cases. And so that's a very challenging setting to mechanize. So if you want to automate your harvest, you can't just find a great machine. You have to standardize. So if you want to automate your harvest you can't just find a great machine. You have to standardize your plants. In other words, you have to make crops more like cars. So in agricultural mechanization, it's not sufficient to take what the person was doing and have a machine do it. You actually have to change the way the agriculture is done or even the nature of the crop to be able to do that. And so agricultural mechanization generally takes the form of making the crops kind of tougher and more consistent where they're more like assembly line objects. And
因此，在农业机械化中，仅仅让机器重复人类所做的事情是远远不够的。你实际上必须改变农业的耕作方式，甚至是作物的性质才能做到这一点。因此，农业机械化通常采取的形式是让作物的质地更坚韧、更一致，使它们更像是流水线上的物品。而对于斯蒂芬妮和她实现辣椒收割自动化的追求来说，
what that means for Stephanie and her quest to automate chili harvests is that even if she found the perfect machine, she would probably continue to have disastrous field tests unless she changed her chili. Which is why for the past five years, most of Stephanie's work has been about breeding a whole new plant, one that is designed specifically to be picked by machine. And so we really haven't done anything much to the machine except for a couple minor modifications. Most of my work has been on breeding lines. Stephanie's ideal chili plant will have to have a few key tricks to make it truly machine friendly. We want a deeper, better anchor taproot on
这意味着即便她找到了完美的机器，除非她改变她的辣椒，否则她很可能会继续面临灾难性的田间测试。这就是为什么在过去五年里，斯蒂芬妮的大部分工作都是培育一种全新的植物，一种专门为机器采摘而设计的植物。所以我们实际上对机器本身没有做太多改动，除了做了一些微小的修改。我的大部分工作都是在育种上。斯蒂芬妮理想的辣椒植物必须具备几个关键特性，才能真正对机器友好。我们希望植物能长出一个更深、抓地更好的主根。
the plant. The roots need to be strong so they don't get ripped out like they did before. Above ground we want a nice strong single stem. We want to grow straight up. We want the green chili fruit lying on the outside of the canopy. Because if they're nestled too deep in the canopy, the harvester can't reach them. In Lethna forget, they also have to taste good. And of course, flavor and heat has to have that good flavor at the process still looking for.
根系必须强壮，这样它们就不会像以前那样被连根拔起。在地面以上，我们希望有一个漂亮的、强壮的单主茎。我们希望它们能笔直向上生长。我们希望青辣椒果实长在冠层的外侧。因为如果它们藏得太深，收割机就够不着它们。最后但同样重要的是，它们必须得好吃。当然，风味和辣度必须具备加工厂仍在寻找的那种好风味。
And to get a plant with all those things, to get everything on her wish list takes time, especially because lots of farmers are wary of GMOs. So Stephanie isn't using any fancy genetic editing techniques. The traditional breeding process requires rubbing, flower parts together in a greenhouse, planting seeds, and waiting to see what you get year after year. And a lot of what you select that looks really good one year does not look the same the coming
要培育出一株具备所有这些特性的植物，把她心愿单上的所有东西都实现是需要时间的，尤其是因为许多农户对转基因作物心存警惕。所以斯蒂芬妮没有使用任何花哨的基因编辑技术。传统的育种过程需要在温室里将花朵部位相互摩擦授粉、播种，然后年复一年地等待结果。而且你挑选出的那些第一年看起来非常棒的特性，在接下来的季节里往往会变样。
season. So it's a whole lot of looking at plants, tasting chili fruit, and then starting the cycle over again. But now, after 15 years of searching for the right machine and breeding peppers that the machine can pick, Stephanie and her team have a combination that has been showing some real promise. And when I visited her in Los Luna, it was time for a final test to see how her special chilies would perform. If this test went well, Stephanie planned to move on to the next step and eventually start providing farmers with these new and improved seeds. went well, Stephanie planned to move on to the next step and eventually start providing farmers with these new and improved seats. So what we have basically here is some varieties
所以，这需要大量地观察植物、品尝辣椒果实，然后周而复始地重新开始这个循环。但现在，经过15年寻找合适机器和培育机器能采摘的辣椒的努力，斯蒂芬妮和她的团队拥有了一个展现出真正前景的组合。当我在洛斯卢纳斯拜访她时，是时候进行最后一次测试，看看她的特种辣椒表现如何了。如果这次测试顺利，斯蒂芬妮计划进入下一步，最终开始向农户提供这些经过改良的优质种子。如果这次测试顺利，斯蒂芬妮计划进入下一步，最终开始向农户提供这些经改良的优质种子。所以我们这里基本上有几种由
that Curry, Chilean, and Seat Company has developed that we just want to see how they pick. We have a couple standard controls, AZ-1904, which is the most commonly grown green Chile currently for commercial production. These standard varieties were there to serve as controls to compare against her special strains. And in the field, I could immediately tell that not all the chili plants there were the same kind. Some were tall and skinny, with big fat peppers.
柯里辣椒种子公司培育的品种，我们只是想看看它们的采摘效果。我们有几个标准对照组，AZ-1904，这是目前商业生产中最常种植的青辣椒品种。这些标准品种在那里作为对照，以便与她的特殊品种进行比较。在地里，我一眼就能看出并不是所有的辣椒植株都是同一种类。有些又高又瘦，结着又大又肥的辣椒；
Others were short and bushy with smaller skinnier peppers, and at the end of the rose sat her newest machine. Believe it or not, it's called the Moses 1000. Perhaps because it was built by a designer in Israel. Stephanie wasn't quite sure. She was more focused on the price. I think he gave us a bit of a deal. I think this was the first. So we've spent, I think it was about 55,000, but I think it would cost closer to 70.
另一些则又矮又密，结着更小、更瘦的辣椒，而在垄的尽头停着她最新的机器。信不信由你，它叫“摩西1000”。也许是因为它是由以色列的一位设计者制造的。斯蒂芬妮不太确定。她更关注的是价格。“我想他给我们打了个折。我想这是第一台。所以我们花了，我想大概是55,000美元，但我觉得实际成本应该接近70,000美元。”
The whole thing was the size of a riding lawnmower, basically, and it had a kind of tear drop shape, with the pointy bit of the tear tilted down at the ground. Inside, there were two really long metal tubes that looked like gigantic drill bits. It was attached to a tractor whose driver maneuvered the whole setup into place. Then, a volunteer flipped a big switch. The drill bits started turning, and the machine slowly began to move through the first row
整个东西基本上和一台驾驶式割草机一样大，呈一种泪滴状，泪滴的尖端朝向地面倾斜。里面有两根非常长的金属管，看起来就像巨大的钻头。它连接在一台拖拉机上，拖拉机司机操纵着整个装置到位。接着，一名志愿者扳下了一个大开关。钻头开始旋转，机器缓缓地驶入第一垄
of peppers. A few rows later, one of Stephanie's collaborators turned to her and said he realized why it's called Moses. I know I know it's called Moses. Oh yeah, why is that? It's floating through that scene. Oh yeah, yeah. Hey, that's right. As it moved along, I could see the metal bits spinning and kind of juzzing up each plant, coaxing the peppers off and carrying them up onto two conveyor belts and into buckets waiting to catch the chillies. In other words, Moses seemed to be working. In addition to not making salsa in the field, Stephanie's breeding lines performed better
辣椒。几垄之后，斯蒂芬妮的一位合作者转向她，说他终于明白为什么它叫“摩西”了。“我知道我知道它为什么叫‘摩西’。”“哦，是吗？为什么？”“因为它能在水面上浮起……哦不对，它是‘在植株间劈波斩浪’。”“哦，对，对。嘿，确实如此。”随着它向前推进，我可以看到金属钻头在旋转，并把每一株植物搅动起来，诱使辣椒脱落，然后将它们带到两条传送带上，送入等待接住辣椒的桶中。换句话说，摩西似乎起作用了。除了没有在田里打出辣椒酱之外，斯蒂芬妮的育种株系表现得比她的对照组更好，
than her controls, which means it wasn't just Moses that was working so well. It was Stephanie's special plants. She's still sifting through the data, trying to figure out exactly how efficiently it all went. But this particular combination of plant and machine might just be it. The holy grail of chilies. Next, Stephanie will have to go through what's called a seed increase, which means it can a whole bunch of these plants so she can distribute the seeds to farmers.
这意味着不仅是摩西运作良好，斯蒂芬妮的特种植物也功不可没。她仍在筛选数据，试图弄清楚这一切的效率到底有多高。但这种植物与机器的特定组合可能真的行之有效。这就是辣椒领域的圣杯。接下来，斯蒂芬妮将不得不经历所谓的种子扩繁，这意味着要种植一大批这样的植物，以便她可以将种子分发给农户。
But the bigger challenge will be convincing farmers to give her seeds and machine a shot because even if it does taste exactly right and the machine works perfectly, not everybody is ready to turn to automation. Back at the chili taste-off, I asked some farmers if they would ever buy a chili-picking machine. Sally Baker, the owner of Genesis Gardens, said, no.
但更大的挑战将是说服农户给她的种子和机器一次尝试的机会，因为即使它的味道完全正确且机器完美运转，也并非所有人都准备好转向自动化。回到辣椒品尝大赛现场，我问一些农户是否会考虑购买一台辣椒采摘机。杰尼斯花园的老板萨利·贝克说，不。
So you would never try to invest in a machine to think of this? Oh no, no. That's not New Mexico and that's not Chile. Oh, okay. So if there was like the perfect machine to pick peppers, you wouldn't go for it. Probably not. That's part of the pleasure in the love of growing Chile. Some Chile farmers like Sally see handpicking as part of the tradition they're trying to defend. It's one of the things that makes it New Mexico Chile. So for a lot of them, the idea of bringing a machine into the field doesn't sit right.
“所以你永远不会考虑投资一台这样的机器来采摘？”“哦不，不。那不是新墨西哥，那也不是辣椒。”“哦，好吧。所以如果有一台完美的机器来摘辣椒，你也不会买账吗？”“可能不会。那是种植辣椒的乐趣和热爱的一部分。”像萨利这样的辣椒农将人工采摘视为他们努力捍卫的传统的一部分。这是让它成为新墨西哥辣椒的元素之一。因此，对他们中的许多人来说，把机器引入田间的想法感觉并不对劲。
Back at his chili farm in Sucoro, Glenn Duggins was skeptical for a different reason. He just didn't think a machine would ever work, but then again, he hadn't seen Stephanie's Do you want to see a video on it? Sure. Alright, so this is the machine. So it goes through and it's got these like helixes and it goes through the plant and it just sort of like shushes up and the plant stays behind. Well, that's looking pretty good, really. Is that worth $70,000? Yeah. $70,000 is not that much labor. Yeah? $70,000 is not that much labor.
回到她在索科罗的辣椒农场，格伦·杜金斯持怀疑态度则是出于不同的原因。他只是觉得机器永远不会起作用，但话又说回来，他还没见过斯蒂芬妮的机器呢。“你想看一段它的视频吗？”“当然。”“好吧，所以这就是这台机器。它开过去，上面有这些螺旋状结构，穿过植株，然后就像这样‘沙沙’地把辣椒捋下来，而植物留在原地。”“嗯，看起来确实挺不错的。这值7万美元吗？”“对。”“7万美元可换不来那么多劳动力。”“是吗？7万美元换不来那么多劳动力。”
And the question is, which of these reactions of the future of New Mexico's chili? Is it Sally Baker who won't even consider a machine? Or is it Glenn Dugins willing to try it to save his business? The answer will come down to what authentic chili actually means in New Mexico. Can a pepper, designed by a scientist and picked by a machine, really compare to a pepper like a Miss Juni, named after the Chili Queen, a 95-year-old whose father used to carry her around in the fields as an infant in a chili pepper sack? Maybe Stephanie just needs a really good branding campaign. After all, when her new line of chili comes out,
问题在于，这些反应中哪一个代表着新墨西哥州辣椒的未来？是萨利·贝克，她甚至不肯考虑机器？还是格伦·杜金斯，愿意为了拯救生意而去尝试它？答案将取决于在新墨西哥州，真正的辣椒究竟意味着什么。一个由科学家设计、由机器采摘的辣椒，真的能比得上像“小琼”这样的辣椒吗？后者以辣椒女王的名字命名，这位95岁老人的父亲过去曾在辣椒麻袋里把她抱在田间地头。也许斯蒂芬妮只是需要一个非常棒的品牌推广活动。毕竟，当她的新系列辣椒问世时，
she'll have to call it something. Do you have any thoughts about the name? No, no, in fact, I don't. I have some ideas that I'm not very happy with. So I'm absolutely. Like what? Oh, I think, well, we looked at Mechina, but I don't really like that.
她得给它取个名字。“你对名字有什么想法吗？”“不，不，事实上，我没有。我有一些自己并不是很满意的想法。所以我完全持开放态度。”“比如呢？”“哦，我想，嗯，我们看过了‘Mechina’，但我其实不太喜欢那个。”
I thought about naming it after people, but I just always worry that it's a jinx. If you name it, name it variety after somebody. In case something goes wrong with it. What about Robocrop? Robocrop? I think you think that I would get a copyright violations for that one, or if they sued me, it might be good publicity for the end of Mexico, Chilean District. Exactly, exactly. Now you're talking. Rose Evelith is the creator of a podcast called Flash4,
“我想过以人的名字来命名，但我总是担心这不吉利。如果你给一个品种冠以某人的名字的话。万一出了什么问题怎么办。”“‘机械作物’（Robocrop）怎么样？”“‘机械作物’？我觉得你会因此惹上版权官司的，或者如果他们起诉我，这对新墨西哥州辣椒产业来说倒是个不错的宣传。”“没错，没错。你这就说到点上了。”罗斯·埃维莱特是一档名为《Flash4》的播客节目的创作者，
which combines audio drama and deep reporting to understand the future. Things like, how would diplomacy work if we couldn't lie? And what would the world look like if we banned cement? The topics are unexpected and mind-expanding, and if you're listening to this, it's probably right up your alley. When we come back, we'll be talking with her about how peppers fit into the wider world of agricultural automation, including the story of a machine that picks a different crop,
该节目将音频广播剧与深度报道结合在一起，以理解未来。比如：如果我们无法说谎，外交会如何运作？如果我们禁用水泥，世界会变成什么样？这些话题出人意料且大开眼界，如果你正在听这个节目，它大概正合你意。稍后，我们将与她探讨辣椒如何契合更广泛的农业自动化世界，包括一个采摘另一种作物的机器的故事，而那个故事最终并没有给人们带来多大帮助。请不要走开。
which did not end up helping people much at all. Stay tuned. So Rose, you produce and host this incredible show, it's called Flash Forward, where you imagine different possible future scenarios. And so you've spent a lot of time pondering the impact that technology will have on society in the future. And in this case, the story that you've just told us about the automation of the chili pepper harvest, it paints this rosy picture like this kind of automation as this
那么罗斯，你制作并主持了这个不可思议的节目，名叫《Flash4》，在节目中你构想了各种可能的未来场景。所以你花了很多时间思考技术在未来对社会产生的影响。在这个案例中，你刚刚给我们讲述的关于辣椒收割自动化的故事，描绘了一幅玫瑰色的图景，将这种自动化视作一种纯粹的好事，只是为了填补劳动力缺口。
unalloyed good that is just there to fill a labor gap. Yeah, totally. And so, but what's funny is that that is usually the opposite narrative that we usually hear. We usually hear robots are taking our jobs and this is horrible and this is a bad thing. Yeah. And in your reporting, you say that in fact, you did come across an example of this phenomenon as well of robots not filling in for missing agricultural workers
是的，完全是这样。但有趣的是，这通常与我们平时听到的叙事截然相反。我们通常听到的是机器人抢走我们的工作，这太可怕了，这是一件坏事。是的。而你在报道中说，事实上，你也确实遇到了这样一个现象的例子，即机器人并没有填补短缺的农业工人，反而取代了他们。你能多讲讲这个故事吗？
but actually displacing them. Could you say a little bit more about that story? Yeah, and it's interesting because it's a story that kind of starts basically the same way as the story of the peppers that we just talked about. So lots of small farmers facing a labor shortage, looking to technology to save them, but it kind of goes to this darker place in that version of the story. So this one starts in the 1950s in California with tomatoes, and specifically what are called processing tomatoes.
是的，很有意思的是，这个故事的开端基本上和我们刚才讨论的辣椒故事一模一样。所以有很多小农户面临劳动力短缺，寄希望于技术来拯救他们，但那个版本的的故事却走向了一个更黑暗的方向。所以这个故事始于20世纪50年代加利福尼亚州的西红柿，具体来说就是所谓的加工西红柿。
And what does that mean? Basically anything that you don't eat fresh. So tomato sauce, tomato paste, canned diced, canned whole, all that kind of stuff that you get in cans. Basically, the grocery store. Right, the ugly tomatoes. Yeah, exactly. And this was a big business in California.
那是什么意思？基本上就是任何你不会新鲜食用的西红柿。比如番茄酱、番茄膏、罐装番茄丁、罐装整番茄，所有你在罐头里买到那种东西。基本上，超市货架上的那些。没错，那些丑西红柿。是的，完全正确。这在加州是一门大生意。
There were about 5,000 farmers in the Central Valley in California growing processing tomatoes. Yeah, exactly. And this was a big business in California. There were about 5,000 farmers in the Central Valley in California growing processing tomatoes. And those farmers relied on migrant workers to pick those tomatoes, and those workers came mostly through something called the breast-cerro program. And what's that? The breast-cerro program is a worker program. It started in World War II as a way to replace the labor that went off to war. And it allowed mostly Mexican workers to come up into the US and work on these farms. And the program actually kept going after the war, and the California tomato industry was completely reliant on these workers. And then in the 1960s, there was this rumor that started going around that the Bracero program was going to finally end.
加州中央谷地大约有5000名农户在种植加工西红柿。是的，完全正确。这在加州是一门大生意。加州中央谷地大约有5000名农户在种植加工西红柿。而这些农户依赖季节工来采摘这些西红柿，这些工人主要通过一个名为“布拉塞罗计划”（Bracero program）的项目来到这里。那是什么？“布拉塞罗计划”是一个劳工项目。它始于二战期间，作为一种填补上前线参战劳动力空缺的方式。它允许主要是墨西哥的工人来到美国并在这些农场工作。战争结束后，这个计划实际上仍在继续，加州的西红柿产业完全依赖这些工人。到了20世纪60年代，开始流传这样一个谣言：“布拉塞罗计划”最终要结束了。
And basically, at that point, tomato farmers sort of freak out. They don't really know what they're gonna do when they don't have workers. Right, and this sounds exactly the same as the chili pepper problem. Exactly, and it gets even more familiar because just like with chili peppers, there were scientists,
基本上，在那一刻，西红柿农户们有点吓坏了。当他们没有工人的时候，他们真的不知道该怎么办。没错，这听起来和辣椒的问题一模一样。
two scientists in particular at UC Davis, who had been working on a tomato harvester and a tomato plant for 10 years at that point. At that point. So they were anticipating the lack of workers at that point. Is that what was going on? It's a good question. The two guys, these two guys at UC Davis, Jack Hannah and Kobe Lorenzen, they were these sort of rogue figures at the time. They started working on this in the 1950s and everybody thought that their whole plan was basically impossible and also kind of ridiculous, because they just thought like, of course we're going to have workers. There's no way we're not going to have workers.
完全一样，而且变得更加似曾相识，因为就像辣椒一样，当时有科学家——加州大学戴维斯分校的两位科学家，他们当时已经研究西红柿收割机和西红柿植物10年了。在那时。所以他们当时就在预测劳动力短缺。当时就是这么回事吗？这是一个好问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的这两个家伙，杰克·汉纳和科比·洛伦森，他们当时是那种离经叛道的人物。他们在20世纪50年代开始研究这个，每个人都认为他们的整个计划基本上是不可能的，而且也有点荒谬，因为他们当时觉得：“我们当然会有工人的。我们绝不可能没有工人。”
There's actually an oral history from the time where they talk about how these two guys were basically the laughing stock of the industry, because everyone thought they were like totally out of their minds. But they did kind of see this future of labor shortage. I think they guessed that the breast-nural program wouldn't be around forever, right? It was just supposed to be this special stopgap during World War II.
实际上当时有一段口述历史，他们谈到这两个家伙基本上是整个行业的笑柄，因为大家都觉得他们完全疯了。但他们的确预见了劳动力短缺的未来。我想他们猜到“布拉塞罗计划”不会永远存在下去，对吧？它本来就只是二战期间的一个特殊的权宜之计。
So they kind of predicted this. So how did this story turn out differently than the story of the peppers? Right, so far, we're basically on track with peppers. But where a difference is that in the case of tomatoes, this worker shortage actually didn't happen. The breast-nural program was eventually terminated, but it wasn't terminated until later.
所以他们某种程度上预测到了这一点。那么这个故事的结局与辣椒的故事有什么不同呢？是的，到目前为止，我们基本上和辣椒的发展轨迹是一致的。但不同之处在于，在西红柿的情况下，这种劳动力短缺实际上并没有发生。“布拉塞罗计划”最终被终止了，但并不是在那个时候终止的。
And so the tomato harvesting machine and the tomato actually came first. And even after the Berserial Program was terminated, there were still workers who wanted to pick these tomatoes. There was still labor, but the farmers had already mechanized anyway. And that's the nightmare scenario for workers right there. Totally a nightmare. Yeah. And they lost their jobs, right?
因此，西红柿收割机和西红柿品种实际上先一步诞生了。即使在“布拉塞罗计划”终止后，依然有工人想要采摘这些西红柿。依然存在劳动力，但农户无论如何都已经实现了机械化。这简直就是工人们的噩梦场景。完全是一场噩梦。是的。他们失业了，对吧？
There were still workers both in the United States and in Mexico who relied on these jobs in the tomato fields. And they were suddenly replaced by this machine and this new tomato variety. And remember, this is the 1960s. So there's no way for these workers to kind of like know that their jobs are gone. They can't text each other and say, hey, don't come. You know, like there's a machine instead. So thousands of farm workers actually showed up at these tomato farms, expecting to pick tomatoes. And so you had 30 or 35,000 people with no work, often with their families, and no money to buy food,
美国和墨西哥依然有许多工人依赖西红柿地里的这些工作。而他们突然就被这台机器和这个新的西红柿品种取代了。记住，这是20世纪60年代。所以这些工人根本没有办法知道他们的工作已经没了。他们不能互相发短信说：“嘿，别来了。你知道的，因为有了一台机器替代了。”所以成千上万的农场工人实际上出现在这些西红柿农场，期待着采摘西红柿。所以你有3万或3万5千人失业了，通常还带着他们的家人，没有钱买食物，
no money to rent housing. They were homeless, and they were penniless. So that's Bill Horger. He's a retired attorney and Bill is important in this tomato story because in the 1960s he worked for an organization called California Rural Legal Assistance and they actually sued the University of California on behalf of these displaced workers. So UC Davis got sued for inventing the tomato picking machine? Yeah, technically the lawsuit wasn't really pinpointing the tomato machine specifically.
没有钱租房子。他们无家可归，身无分文。这是比尔·霍格。他是一位退休律师，比尔在这个西红柿故事中很重要，因为在20世纪60年代，他曾为一个名为“加州乡村法律援助”的组织工作，他们实际上代表这些失业工人起诉了加利福尼亚大学。所以加州大学戴维斯分校因为发明了西红柿采摘机而被起诉了？是的，严格来说，这场诉讼其实并不是专门针对西红柿机的。
It was about whether the University of California, which is a public land-grant university, specifically Davis, should be using its funds to work on projects that benefit these big corporations, these bigger farms, at the expense of family farmers and workers. And when this lawsuit started, Bill actually didn't even work for CRLA, and the way he actually got involved is that CRLA was trying to recruit him to work for them for a completely different job.
问题在于加州大学作为一个公立赠地大学，特别是戴维斯分校，是否应该利用资金去开展那些造福这些大公司、大农场，却损害家庭农场主和工人利益的项目。当这场诉讼开始时，比尔甚至不在加州大学农村法律援助组织（CRLA）工作，他参与进来的方式其实是，CRLA正试图招募他去做一份完全不同的工作。
But he had this long history of working for marginalized groups, marginalized people, and when he heard about this case, it really spoke to him. So when he was interviewing for this other unrelated job, he sort of was just like, forget about that. I want something else. I said to the then executive director on the phone, I said, look, stop talking to me about this position you're offering me. I don't want it. I do want to come in and take
但他有着长期为边缘化群体、边缘化人群工作的历史，当他听到这个案件时，深深地打动了他。因此，当他面试另一份不相关的工作时，他基本上就想，算了吧，我想要别的。我当时在电话里对当时的执行董事说，听着，别再跟我谈你提供给这个职位了，我不想要。我确实想进来接手
over this lawsuit. And I got hired to do that. That's exciting. That was exciting. And this lawsuit, like, actually got a ton of attention at the time. It was covered in the New York Times. It was on the radio. And for Bill, it was this huge moment in his career. Frankly, I came back from my honeymoon the night before the opening of the trial. I had a two-day honeymoon because my wedding coincided with the
这个诉讼。然后我被雇佣来做这件事。这太令人兴奋了。这确实很令人兴奋。而且这场诉讼当时实际上受到了极大的关注。《纽约时报》进行了报道，电台也播出了。对比尔来说，这是他职业生涯中的一个巨大时刻。坦白说，我在庭审开幕前一天晚上从蜜月回来。我只有两天的蜜月，因为我的婚礼与
last weekend before the new trial. And I came back from that to walk into the courtroom Monday morning and give this opening statement. And there were probably 15 to 20 television cameras, every network, every radio station, and I had never been in an arena like that. So Bill's main argument in this case was that the tomato harvesting machine, not only hurt Californian farm workers by taking away their jobs, but it also hurt small family farmers. The UC Davis machine, it's really expensive, and to kind of make it work economically for a farmer, you have to have a big farm with a lot of tomatoes to harvest. The funding was being used deliberately in many cases to promote large-scale corporate agriculture and that was an explicit purpose that one can find in reading research proposals at the time. So he was trying to show that what automation was in this case was not sort of science making a world more prosperous for everybody, but instead it was this sort of way for big agriculture to
新审判前的最后一个周末重合了。我从蜜月回来，星期一早上走进法庭，发表了这篇开场白。当时大概有15到20台电视摄像机，各大电视网、各大广播电台都在，我从来没有见过那样的场面。所以比尔在这个案件中的主要论点是，番茄采收机不仅通过夺走工作岗位伤害了加州的农场工人，还伤害了小型家庭农场主。加州大学戴维斯分校的机器非常昂贵，为了让它对农民来说在经济上可行，你必须拥有一个种植大量番茄的大农场来收获。在许多情况下，资金被刻意用于推广大规模的企业化农业，这是一个可以在当时的研究提案中明确找到的明确目的。因此，他试图表明，这次的自动化并不是那种让世界对每个人都更加繁荣的科学，相反，它只是大农业的一种方式，旨在
grab market share such that everybody but them loses. So did they end up winning this case? but then loses. So did they end up winning this case? No. Because they have a good point. They do have a really good point. And in fact, you know, the trial goes forever. It goes on for over 10 years. They go through two different judges, several appeals, and ultimately, they lose the case. But like you say, they have a good point. And Bill was ultimately sort of right in just five years after the release of this tomato variety and the picker not only did all of these people lose their jobs, but 4,428 of the 5,000 tomato growers actually went out of business. In their place, these mega farms they took over the land. And today, if you drive along the 99 in Central Valley in California, you can see these giant
争夺市场份额，结果是除了他们之外所有人都输了。那么他们最后赢得这个诉讼了吗？但随后又输了。那么他们最后赢得这个诉讼了吗？没有。因为他们的观点很有道理。他们的观点确实非常好。事实上，你知道，这场审判持续了很久。它持续了10多年。他们经历了两位不同的法官、数次上诉，最终他们输了官司。但就像你说的，他们有道理。而且比尔最终在某种程度上是对的，在这个番茄品种和采收机发布后的短短五年内，不仅所有这些人失去了工作，而且5000个番茄种植者中有4428个实际上破产了。取而代之的是，这些超级农场接管了土地。今天，如果你沿着加州中央山谷的99号公路开车，你可以看到这些巨大的
tomato harvesting machines harvesting tomatoes for processing. And those are a direct descendant of that UC Davis project. So, you know, if you put this together with the Pepper Story, there's really, you know, two sides of this argument. Automation could be a good thing to address labor shortages or it could be a bad thing and the robots take over jobs that don't need to be taken over. So, I know this's unfair to ask,
番茄采收机正在为加工厂收割番茄。这些都是加州大学戴维斯分校那个项目的直系后代。所以，如果你把这与辣椒的故事结合起来，这个论点实际上有两个方面。自动化可能是解决劳动力短缺的好事，也可能是坏事，机器人接管了本不需要被取代的工作。所以，我知道问这个很不公平，
but you do a speculative podcast, which is it? Like which is more true? The tables have turned. Normally I'm the one asking the question. I don't know why I should. I mean, I do think it's kind of both and neither, right? So in some cases, like in the pepper case,
但你做的是一个推测性的播客，到底是哪一个？哪个更真实？风水轮流转。通常我是问问题的那个人。我不知道我为什么要这样。我的意思是，我确实认为两者都有，又都不是，对吧？所以在某些情况下，比如辣椒的例子，
there really is this labor shortage. And in some cases, these jobs are bad and dangerous. And if people can find work in better arenas, that is a good thing. In other cases, the good jobs, the well-paying, safe union jobs, those are actually the ones that are being automated. In fact, David Otter, who you heard earlier coined a term, he calls Polani's Paradox, which is this idea that the hardest jobs to automate are often the ones that people call quote unquote low skill,
确实存在劳动力短缺。在某些情况下，这些工作既糟糕又危险。如果人们能在更好的领域找到工作，这是一件好事。在其他情况下，那些好工作、薪水优厚、安全且有工会保障的工作，实际上正是那些正在被自动化的工作。事实上，你刚才听到的戴维·奥特创造了一个词，他称之为“波兰尼悖论”，这个观点是：最难自动化的工作往往是那些人们称之为“低技能”的工作，
things like McDonald's employee, line cook, dishwasher. Those jobs are actually often the things that machines can't do. They're really hard for machines to do. But the easy jobs to automate are often the ones that we call kind of good middle class jobs, things like accounting, and even a union car assembly line job. Those are the jobs that people actually want, and they're the ones that the robots are really good at taking.
比如麦当劳员工、短工厨师、洗碗机操作员。这些工作实际上往往是机器做不到的。机器很难做到这一点。但容易自动化的工作往往是我们所谓的中产阶级好工作，比如会计，甚至是工会的汽车装配线工作。这些才是人们真正想要的工作，而机器人却非常擅长把它们夺走。
Thank you, Rose. Thanks. 99% invisible was produced this week by Rose Eveleth, edited by Joe Rosenberg, mixed in tech production by Srivusif, music by Sean Rial. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kirk Colstad, is the digital director. The rest of the team is Emmett Fitzgerald, Avery Truffman, Delaney Hall, Chris Baroubaix, Sophia Klotzkar, Vivian Leigh, and me Roman Mars. Rose interviewed a bunch of amazing people for this story whose voices we weren't able to fit into the episode,
谢谢你，罗斯。谢谢。本周的《99%无形》由罗斯·埃维莱特制作，乔·罗森伯格编辑，斯里维苏夫进行混音和技术制作，肖恩·里亚尔配乐。凯蒂·明格是我们的资深制作人，柯克·科尔斯塔德是数字总监。团队的其他成员包括埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德、埃弗里·特鲁夫曼、德兰尼·霍尔、克里斯·巴鲁贝、索菲亚·克洛茨卡、薇薇安·李以及我——罗曼·马尔斯。罗斯为这个故事采访了一群了不起的人，由于篇幅原因，我们没能把他们的声音剪进单集里，
but we want to give special credit and thanks to Stony Stroder, the executive director of the New Mexico Chilli Association, Brad Tonneson, who works with Stephanie on her breeding lines and Alan Van Dines, who works on pepper breeding at UC Davis and who told Rose to talk to Stephanie in the first place. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland California 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all a podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find
但我们要向新墨西哥州辣椒协会执行董事斯托尼·斯特罗德、与斯蒂芬妮合作培育品种的布拉德·托内森，以及在加州大学戴维斯分校从事辣椒育种并最初告诉罗斯去采访斯蒂芬妮的阿兰·范戴恩致以特别的谢意和感谢。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心广播街的 Radio Row 制作。在美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心的 Radio Row 制作。99%无形是来自 PRX 的 RadioTopia 成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的坚定的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 查找所有这些节目。你可以在
the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook you can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI or on Instagram and Reddit too. But we will make you hungry for chilies, both red and green at 99PI.org. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论，你可以在推特上@我（Roman Mars）或@节目（99PI），也可以在Instagram和Reddit上找到我们。但我们会在 99PI.org 上让你对红绿辣椒垂涎欲滴。来自 PRX。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。